(ambient noises from outdoors)
- [Mark] All right, Rita.
Welcome back.
- [Rita] Hi, I guess.
- [Mark] So, you were
just telling me outside
that you actually prefer
to be living on the street
than in the hospital that you were in?
- I don't wanna go back to the hospital.
I don't want them to tell me what to do,
and they don't give you seconds
when they give you your medication,
and I be hungry when I get up.
And what's important to me is
I wanna be like these ladies
that have nice clothes and look nice.
But I went to visit a friend,
and I wanted some food,
and they had a lot left
and they threw it away
because in the Allison,
the security said I'm nasty
and I got a disease, and I got AIDS,
and they don't want me in they building
'cause I'm nasty and ugly.
And they be havin', all the
other securities have meetings
about me and don't nobody
like me because I'm retarded.
And I said, "I'm special."
And they said they don't want nobody
who can't read and write
'cause they retarded and dirty.
And my mama (crosstalk)--
- [Mark] They didn't feed you?
- And they threw all
the food away right now.
And I almost was cryin' because
they gave a girl some food
that I be visitin' and
they had a lot of food
and they wouldn't even let me
get none out the garbage can,
they told me to get back.
They don't like me, and
I didn't do nothin'.
- [Mark] So, you actually prefer,
I mean, you live on the street,
you don't even have a tent, right?
- No, I don't wanna be by my...
I wanna be by myself, I don't
wanna be with nobody 'cause--
- [Mark] What's wrong with the hospital?
- Only my mama.
At the hospital, they keep
you locked up in a room
and you eat in a hall, and
they give me medication,
but when they give me food,
lunch and breakfast and stuff,
they don't give me seconds.
- [Mark] What does your
typical day look like
here living in Skid Row?
- I just wanna be like my friend,
she take me to her house
and give me clothes
but she makes me, she tell
me to go make some money
and pay for her clothes
because she doin' it
'cause I'm her friend
but she need help too.
- [Mark] So your typical day here
on the street is what, what do you do?
- I walk around and I just be happy.
I talk to my mother too, my
mother said she's coming back.
My mama said she's gone come back.
My mother tell me and
God, my mother tell me
to just stay to myself, and then she...
I go and sit on the corner,
and then a man stops sometimes,
they look at my body, they give me money,
and they take me to eat.
(interviewer sighs)
- [Mark] So people are
nice to you on the street,
or mean to you or little
bit of (crosstalk)?
- Some peoples is nice but
I just wanna be by myself
'cause when they nice,
I gotta give them money
when I don't feel like givin' 'em.
Makin' money, I just feel like just peace,
me and God and my mother,
but I have to or I can't be on the street.
- [Mark] Do you get robbed sometimes?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Have you been robbed a few times?
- No, I give it to 'em if they tell me to.
- [Mark] Oh, I see.
- I share anything I got because God said
you gotta share a blessing.
But only thing happened to me
is I give my sugar boat to--
- [Mark] Your what?
- They take my sugar boat
down there, a lot o' times.
- [Mark] They take your what?
- Sugar boat, they give me, you know,
sometimes on this street,
they give me rocks,
and then they say, "Let's party,
I don't want nuttin' from you."
And then when I party, I
gotta give 'em my body.
- [Mark] (softly) Oh, I see.
- And then I just do it so they
won't kill me and my money.
- [Mark] And yet you still prefer
to live on the street
than in the hospital?
- Yeah, because nobody like me.
- [Mark] So Rita, tell me
about your mom and dad.
- My mom and dad, when I was young,
my dad and mom get drunk,
he used to drown my mom
in a bathtub and put the water on,
and make it real, real
hot, and she'd be screamin'
and then I'll hold her hand
and tell her it's okay,
he tell me to shut up, and I go in there
and run out the bathroom and get a broom
and hit 'im in the back
o' his head and stuff.
And he'd run after me, my mom'd hurry up
and get out the bathtub
and run out the door
and go call the police.
My dad, when they not drinkin',
he don't got time for my mom.
My mom said that's not my
dad, they were just young
and partyin' and she got pregnant by 'im,
but she wanted us to know our dad.
But he tried to kill her a lot o' times.
And I run in a closet and cover up
with some clothes on my head.
And I'd be scared and run in a closet,
shut the closet, cover my head up,
'cause I don't wanna see it.
And then when he make
my mom bloody, he leave,
she hurried and lock the
door and come and get me,
and rocked me while she
cleanin' herself up.
I still be with my mom, I love my mom.
'Cause my sister live in Sacramento,
she call me "retarded" too.
And she don't want my
nieces and 'em around me,
'cause they say I'm
wearin' the same clothes
I got the virus, and
I'm ugly and retarded,
and she made 'em leave me alone.
But I go to the Union
Station, and they help me
and I give it to her,
so I wouldn't be cold.
Only when it's cold and
rainin', I could stay with her.
- [Mark] I think you're wearing
the same clothes as last time.
- Yeah, 'cause I couldn't get none.
With the money, I gave her some,
and then I bought some food for her house.
And then I bought some rock.
But I bought food first--
- [Mark] You say you brought rock--
- Yeah, I gave her some.
- [Mark] You mean crack.
- Well yeah, I didn't buy it,
I give her some money, her give me some.
- [Mark] 'Kay.
- But I take everything to her,
unless'n I just go and
buy the stuff, food first.
I don't buy drugs 'cause
they takes my money.
I don't buy drugs, I let
somebody give it to me or buy it.
'Cause I'm scared, you know,
mostly my peoples, they don't like me.
Last night, security, he was callin' me
all kinds a nasty A- prostitute,
and said all of the securities
be laughin' every day
and talkin' about me and havin' a meeting
of how retarded I am.
And that's sad, and then I'm
not good like these people
and my mother told me I was
just special and different,
but they say that I'm retarded,
to be around them I need
to learn how to read,
and to dress better than I do.
- [Mark] Oh, you dress beautifully.
- It's clean, but she...
The lady who was here,
she don't wanna give me
no more o' her clothes.
- [Mark] Are you cold at night?
- She gave me this...
Is I'm cold (crosstalk)?
Yeah, but I get on the
train, when it's real cold,
I get on the train, and at
her house I got a medication.
I got a pump and a machine, and inhaler.
I got a gray one and a orange one.
- [Mark] Could I buy you a jacket?
- I got...
Yeah, you got a jacket?
- [Mark] Yeah, I'll--
- 'Cause a man, he gave me that jacket.
He had it on layin' on the ground,
and he gave it to me last night.
- [Mark] Okay, well I
can give you something
a little warmer maybe.
- Okay.
- [Mark] Where do you normally sleep?
- Me?
- [Mark] Yeah.
- At the mostly, 'cause when I'm scared,
'cause if one person tell
me that they want my body
and I ain't got it, if
I got money, I'd say,
"I'll give you some money, but
please don't take my body."
And then I'd just go
catch the bus real fast
when I give 'em the money and say,
"I'mma go somewhere to me
somethin' to snack on."
I'd tell a story and I'd get on the bus,
and go to train station.
- [Mark] And you don't get money
from Social Security or any like that?
- No, sir.
- [Mark] So every dollar that you--
- I got the letter and anything
that they's gonna help me, so...
- [Mark] But right now,
the only money that you get
is from the money you make on the street?
- Yeah.
I ask for donations.
People at the grocery store give me food,
then I take it to her,
so we could share it.
But she my best friend,
she try to help me.
And then we play a little
game of alphabets and stuff...
(people faintly talking in the background)
Like a puzzle.
- [Mark] All right, Rita, well I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make your day a
little easier, at least.
(Rita mumbles softly)
(sighs) Well thank you
for coming in again.
- Yeah, you got some food here?
- [Mark] I have some money for ya.
I'll set you up with some food (chuckles).
- Okay, all right.
- [Mark] You can go
anywhere you like for lunch.
- Okay, I'mma go cross the street.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- The Mexicans and the Caucasian guy,
'cause I got a stepdad,
he's a truck driver,
but he live in Big Bear, and
he only come once a month.
His name is (name muted) and
since I came to California '98,
he take care o' me, but he don't no more
because they told 'im that I can't ride
with him on the road, and
it's too far for him to come.
- [Mark] Hmm.
- [Rita] But yeah--
- [Mark] A'right well, if
you ever get into a jam,
you come see me, okay?
- [Rita] Okay.
- [Mark] If you ever
need help with anything.
- [Rita] Yeah.
- [Mark] Excellent.
- [Mark] A'right Rita, well
thank you for coming in.
- [Rita] Thank you, you welcome.
- [Mark] It's great to see you again.
- [Rita] Yes.
Am I a movie star?
(interviewer laughs)
I told the people that I'm a movie star.
- [Mark] (laughs) You are a movie star.
- [Rita] 'Cause they put
some wires and stuff.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Rita] (voice becoming
distant) Well, you know...
Uh-oh, I got this (removing
sound equipment)...
I wanted to be on Dancing With the Stars,
but I came here and my (voice fades out).
- [Woman] (voice fading
in) Some more food.
- [Mark] Who's that?
- Rita Calvin!
- [Mark] Hey, what'd ya got?
- And he bought me some clothes!
And I got a skirt too, a go-go skirt.
And I got some tennis shoes.
(interviewer chuckles)
God sent my friend in my life,
I got a lotta pretty clothes,
over there on Los Angeles Street.
- [Mark] But, with the money I gave you?
- Yes!
- [Mark] Oh, I see, okay.
- I went shop, I came back--
- [Mark] Look at you, you look beautiful.
- Thank you, I came back to
show you, but you wasn't here.
- [Mark] Oh, I'm here today.
- I got some tennis shoes,
socks, and a skirt--
- [Mark] You look so stylish.
- And a shirt--
- [Mark] You're beautiful.
- Thank you, so I'm
lookin' cute like them now.
- [Mark] Yeah, you look
cuter than they do.
You look great (crosstalk).
All right, darlin'.
- Yeah, thank, now I
need a coat and a radio!
- [Mark] A coat and a radio?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] I already got a coat,
I got two coats for you right here.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Mark] Take your pick.